are you guys doing good yeah thank you
so you guys world premiered removi last
night what the hell is it like - world
premiere a movie I mean it's it's like a
once-in-a-lifetime experience for me
this is my first time here and the film
means so much to me and we put so much
love and hard work into it it was just
incredible to see it on the big screen
and not even having had a cast and crew
just the very first time an audience had
seen it and I so nervous I almost didn't
join in and sit down but I think it's
really important to be there for that
and I'm really glad that I did do it I
was just I was you know my stomach just
not yeah it was you know to be there and
to see people reacting to it and witness
people's behavior during the film and
how they responded to it yeah I would
say that almost every single person
watching this interview will not have
seen the movie yet so I hate asking the
generic question but can you talk a
little bit about who you play what the
film is about however it gradually gets
slightly more eerie and sinister
mysterious set in Snowdonia during the
industrial revolution yeah my it's my
character kind of growing up and taking
on the responsibilities of becoming an
adult in the face of this hostile
community and the hostilities of nature
as well that's that plays a big part in
it and obviously the landscape as a
whole that that's a huge part of the
film - I was gonna say one of the things
as I watched it was there's just a real
sense of dread as you're watching you're
like you know it's just I don't want to
curse on camera but the [ __ ] keeps going
back feeling and it's like you know
worse and worse talk a little bit about
in the writing process because you have
a lot of interesting shots of like
nature and you know
how is that in the script in terms of
the way you wrote it and how much is it
you know figuring out how you're gonna
do it on set well I think you hit the
nail on the head with what dread it was
one of the our frame or outside of the
dark waiting I grew up in a rural
community and I even man that just hear
noises outside like even as a kid I
didn't know the sound of foxes is
suctioning could be noise and how your
mind will play tricks on you I want to
take that idea of trying to understand
the unknown and how terrifying that can
be especially in this isolated farm that
we have the film set in so yeah really
the film is a journey through dread and
tension and just use that eerie
landscape I think that's the that's one
of the big I think experience is people
took away from it but the premiere
really which was really fun to see yeah
well we say but how is that in the
script in terms of our you know what I
mean because there are those quiet
moments like there's a few shots where
it's like you know through the window or
just like these tranquil things and
you're building up this sense so how is
it on the page or do you know what I
mean yeah I mean it definitely didn't
write this bit is really tense or it's
like it's hard because you you want to
give a sense the tone so I do describe
the landscape and hopefully try and give
a feeling through that that hopefully is
maybe helpful to you but then some of
the shots you find and you idea comes to
you from the space so the landscape so
the opening of the second shot
the opening scene which is on that rock
almost monolithic looking rock is the
location that I found just exploring the
area so wrote into the film because if
it's just inherently mythological creepy
feeling quality how was it for you
reading this book how how did you get
attached to the project I'm assuming you
went in and auditioned did you yeah yeah
so I meant well and we we had a meeting
and then I I went in again and we kind
of like went through a couple of scenes
and talked it through and then it all
just kind of went through there it was
like a real
easy birth did he tell you at the time
by the way we're you know no makeup
we're gonna you know the outfits the
whole thing I mean yeah I turned up for
my audition looking you know I wash my
hair or no makeup I'm not particularly a
girl ego in that sense I didn't really
mind you know just turning up as I am
but November and December yeah yeah that
was cool for each of you I always am
curious about memorable moments from
filming like what's the day you're
always gonna remember wow I feel like
every single day there was something
that happened where it was just well the
day we turned up to set and we could we
had to take all the lights down because
we're 70 mile an hour wind outside or
the day we had to evacuate a location
because it flooded or the day that when
it snowed so no the continuity match all
the day whether there was an actual
blizzard so we just decided to film it
anyway because it looked really cool I
rewrote the scene to work in the weather
that one looked look nice now it was a
cool one we were constantly battling
those conditions yeah but comes across
in the film I think yeah was that the
day that you're going to the next-door
neighbor's house certainly one of the
days yeah just started it was great I'm
always curious about the editing process
cuz that's the final rewrite how much of
what you wrote resembles like the final
finished film that people end up seeing
along the process I have quite a fluid
approach anyway so there are scenes that
aren't scripted that we shot that just
felt right or the idea came to us and
there's scenes where there was dialogue
and then we shot without any dialogue
yeah so I keep that process going so I'm
I know that I'm looking to further the
story get inside your character's head
to keep the dread building so I'm really
quite open-minded in the edit and if the
editors got a suggestion about you know
what this scene isn't serving the story
it's not
helping us learn anything more about
Gwen quite happy for it to go
so quite yeah I think I like keeping it
fluid really the whole process just
being open-minded how long was your
first cut compared to the finished film
not longer probably only like five or so
minutes long as there's nothing dramatic
no I mean we we shot for five weeks and
I think in that time that's you know we
got all the material we could in and it
wouldn't it was never like a you know
three hour assembly
yeah maybe maybe five minutes is
understanding a little bit but it wasn't
much longer it's all I'm for for both of
you
I'm always also curious about challenges
of making the film so for you what was
the big challenge in actually an acting
question a lot of times like when I
speak to people at actors they talk
about how the first they have to figure
out the first thing about the character
and once they break through and get that
one thing then all of a sudden all makes
sense so what was that first thing you
needed to figure out or how did you
break in I think for me that that first
breakthrough it was probably the accent
it's a it's like a specific north well
shucks and and I was very lucky because
a lot of the crew were from the area
that I needed to base the accent on so
the minute I could actually feel as if
I'd got the character's voice and that
you know I'd kind of captured that then
it meant that I could work on the rest
of the character and kind of feel that I
was based where where she was I was kind
of in her world at that point I just
lost my train of thought but it was
talking about like once you've got the
green light and you knew you're gonna
make the movie what was the big
challenge that you really felt like the
one that you were very scared about I
think finding the right tone for the
film because I loved genre and photo is
a real inspiration to me I also really
enjoy Bergman and I wanted to tell a
story that felt emotional and really
character driven so finding that balance
of the genre moment
and how that plays in the film and not
not betraying the genre or not giving
people the wrong expectation and I think
that was always a tightrope that we were
walking you with there's a few what I
would call jump scares in the movie
people could have a reaction were you
did you look at any films prior to did
you look at any films to see like how
you wanted to set it up or was it sort
of a culmination of all the films you'd
watched yes oh I I loved a lot of the
sort of old British Horrors there's a
trilogy unholy trilogy which is kind of
beginning of folk horror and I've always
been a fan of horror but I kind of
looked to films more recent even like it
comes at night and the witch where they
are horror but they cross over into
something else and they are sort of in
this sort of world between genres and
that's one of the things with this film
is that I think I want to I want to be
careful about how much I talk about the
climax of the film what happens because
I've been avoiding it yeah I really
enjoy and that was the beautiful thing
about yesterday the audience not having
an expectation we actually changed the
title of the film to remove some of the
expectations people might have so you go
in and you go on the journey and these
things unfold in front of you and that
that impact I mean we can't hold onto
that forever people are gonna find out
but I think it's a really it's an
important part of the storytelling for
me if the fit of this film it's so funny
my next question was literally how did
you decide on the title when and what
were the alternate titles but I guess
you shouldn't say them well I don't mind
um it's all on IMDB anyway um so
interestingly going back to dread it was
called the dark outside just because
that's where dread comes from the fear
of what's in the dark outside but that
title sets an expectation from the
get-go of horror and our our film for
the first 20 minutes barely has any
music and it's all about you and the
world you live in so I think that's
misleading so I think Gwen really just
for me focus the film down to it's about
you and your experience in your journey
that journey goes into a dark place
one of the things I really appreciate it
is I feel like I love it when films
capture a moment in history
where you feel like you're actually
there it felt very authentic you know
that that we were in that moment so talk
about like trying to be as authentic as
you can to that time period and the
research you did to make yourself feel
comfortable to be able to act that way
you know so we went to the sleep museum
in Columbus which is in the general area
where we were shooting and we spoke to a
historical expert but we weren't kind of
limiting ourselves to you know the
particular social standards at the time
it was great to have a basis for it and
to kind of explore what you couldn't
couldn't do but it wasn't like a rigid
kind of rule that we had to stick by
yeah I had feedback from historical
experts that we worked with during the
script as well and is always good to
know like the clapping game is
historically inaccurate and you wouldn't
have played it but the option I was
given was noughts and crosses I just
thought that wasn't very cinematics we
broke a few rules it's not the only one
we broke sometimes you just you know
take the research learn from it decide
where the teased or not yeah it's still
it's also just beautiful occasions I
would what was there ever taught a
little bit about finding the location
and why you wanted that particular the
way it's setting yeah sure so I loved
the effect of the sublime and we're
talking about Dredd in Erie I think a
lot of that comes from landscape and I
think in the UK we have these incredible
landscapes which gave birth to folk
tradition and folk beliefs and that was
something incredible to play with so I
actually went and stayed out in
Snowdonia would just go rent a cottage
spend all morning walking around finding
locations and then the afternoon I'd
spend writing
so a lot of the things that I would find
and photographed during the day would
inform what I wrote later on and so that
was quite a nice process to have I was
gonna say it's the locations actually
caused inspiration for the movie yeah
definitely I've been asking I've been
having everyone who comes in play
something called get to know your TIF
attendee and you guys are about to play
telling you it's pretty simple and you
will know
be upset okay I hope so what for you
what TV show would you love to guest
spot on and for you what TV show would
you love to guest write and direct Wow
oh that's a difficult one you can give
two sickos if you have to oh my can you
go first black mirror cuz they're
incredible and I think they reflect on
what what we're experiencing our
day-to-day lives and do something
incredibly interesting with it and each
one is its own standalone thing and the
people they get involved is just
brilliant so yeah I'm just gonna hop on
the back of that yeah be in my black do
you have a favorite sci-fi or fantasy
film I'm I don't watch a lot of sci-fi
sure but when I was a kid I used to
absolutely love watching anything
fantastical or you know I was obsessed
with fairy tales and oh yeah sure yeah
like don't would start I mean Dark
Crystal but I know it's a labyrinth I
love all like something that just
connected to my childhood like that
lonely just resonates with me and I'm
really excited to see another TV series
but His Dark Materials trilogy sure
because a big fan of the books and I
can't wait to see that so yeah what
films scared you as a kid Oh what film
didn't scare me as a gift
oh gosh I can't remember the first
horror film I ever watched but I
certainly remember as a kid there were
there was certain I remember being
scared and scooby-doo that was that was
the first time I ever had a nightmare
there was an episode of scooby-doo that
terrified me I don't know which one what
happened there was an old man and he was
walking around saying come come to me or
something scary like that so yeah
that was probably the first time and the
thing that she's not telling us is it
was when she was 14 I remember
you know how he just as a kid like
you're up late watching TV and I didn't
know what it was at the time but it was
a young vampire animation and it was
these it was just these faces of clay
and they were just changing that was
always just stayed with me because it
was out of context I don't know what it
was I just stumbled across it late-night
TV and actually kind of use that as
inspiration of I almost want people when
they've watched something that I've made
to feel like they've turned on the TV
late at night and stumbled across
something strange they otherwise
wouldn't have discovered so I still have
stuck with me actually is there anything
that you collect I don't I don't think
so unless we're talking about hat eyes
or some very interesting answer
Pro P blu-rays to be honest I say sure
yeah that's kind of an obvious answer I
guess no no I a lot of people have moved
more into like streaming you know in
terms of I think it's it takes it takes
a yeah this is the thing with my blu-ray
collection it's like I don't want to own
everything
it's curated so it's like what I really
want to have oh now what happens if
someone gives you like a free blu-ray do
you accept it and add it to the
collection no separate shelf so it's
like really it is highly curated do you
own any movie or TV show props I mean
apart from the stuff I've worked on oh
you've stolen a couple years ago and I
rarely take it off but that's it's
special to me because it's kind of a
memory and my first big TV break and it
kind of brings me back to that I keep
all the clapper boards for things I
worked on a little hot from someone
stole ours on Gwen's so I didn't know
that really if they watch this interview
that that sucks yeah oh we lost in the
mud yes it would be such a collectible
what would people be surprised to learn
about you
besides you're scared by scooby-doo
almost had a Korean professional rugby
part from I dislocated both my knees so
although I'm quite a big guy so maybe
that's not that surprising it's a good
answer yep I've never broken a bone
there you go there's that's something
goes quite well with no have you ever
watched a TV show all the way through
more than once called mostly comedy yeah
select off my knees dark place or you
just what is the background photo on
your phone my dog I'm pretty basic from
Gwen if you're walking out into the yeah
have you what have you ever watched a
movie more than 20 times definitely as a
kid
I'm sure there's bound to be at least
several Disney films or maybe over 30
you know is there or 40 for you or 50
because I've seen Star Wars or like
certain movies you know probably more
than 50 times I'm being honest try not
to do too many repeat viewings though
because am I to watch list gives me
anxiety yeah yes always getting longer
yeah you know I I have that same issue
with TV there's just an abundance of
amazing television yeah and I that's a
thing but if speaking of gladiator if
you're here tomorrow Hans Zimmer will be
here I I've got that in my iCal and
editor I really like Joe walkers don't
be [ __ ] - yeah yeah he'll be there for
that say FYI
we'll talk off camera do you have a
favorite pair of sneakers or shoes
whichever is easiest to put on together
flat on time to get to set normally yes
is it okay to say slippers like you're
Heidi bad slippers represent absolutely
do you met my last question for you
do you remember what got you interested
in wanting to be in the entertainment
industry it's hard to pin it down I just
used to love right story ideas and
taking pictures and I just inherited a
little handycam and started making
documentaries on the farm I grew up and
just filming and I think it was probably
seeing like up behind the scenes which
is one thing that streaming is killing
is that that sort of like director's
commentary and behind the scenes and
that's actually where I started to
realize that people made these films
yeah
and I could maybe do it too one day
mm-hmm I think I knew from a very young
age it was what I wanted to do it was
always in me I mean my first day of
nursery I climbed to the top of a
bookcase and sung hey big spender - the
whole classroom so you know in the film
right must improvise this scene
[Music]
surprised to learn about you yeah it was
it was always something that I wanted to
do but I didn't know it was something
that children could actually pursue I
thought it was like a very select amount
of people that were adults who were
allowed to do that that's the funny
things you've actually got more
experience than I it all fell into place
and completely I listen I really mean it
congratulations on the movie it really
it really captures that sense of dread
and you know unknowing as you're
watching and I think I messed up at the
beginning of this interview by not
saying a huge thank you to house of
Aurora who are our sponsor and awesome
and I so appreciate them partnering up
with us to make interviews like this
possible here at the Toronto Film
Festival on that note thank you both so
much for coming in
enjoy the rest of the vest thank you
very much
[Music]